e oggi nuova challenge slime ingrediente
grande versus slime ingrediente piccolo
non potevamo fare di bill e questa per
me li mangiamo
no perché come forse era che se
challenge una volta testa andremo a
mettere in questa scatola un ingrediente
di questo ingrediente una sarà grande e
uno sarà piccolo una persona non saprà
che ingrediente c'è e quindi dovrà
scegliere se sceglie l'ingrediente
piccolo gabriel e diete grande come
starebbe pensando ma è sempre meglio
scegliere gli ingredienti grandi così
essendo slimer gigante in realtà no
perché potrebbero esserci degli
ingredienti brutti che è meglio farne
meno quindi è meglio scegliere piccolo
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere una seconda parte di questa
challenge se questo video raggiungere il
10 mila mica se faremo anche la seconda
parte come tale si mangerà tutto il
frigorifero se ti vediamo chi inizia
carta fuori casa su piattaforme
[Musica]
vitale ora si deve andare a più giriamo
lo schermo così lui non riusciva a
vedere da lì e vado a mettere il mio
primo ingrediente vivendo è veri e non
guardare ma mi raccomando controllate
queste vitale sbircia nel fratello
passeggiando marzan baruffa alimenti di
avati ha messo la maschera sentire
l'amore puoi ascoltare ma non puoi
guardare sono delle queste di plastica
allora aspetta che giro uno schermo
ok un po di die hard in ammenda non male
dentro la scatola via mare poi però lo
schermo scegli grande o piccolo allora
gli ego piccolo come mai perché magari
sei un ingrediente brutto e meglio
averne poco di averne tanto e sei un
indigente e bene però mi potresti avere
troppo poco
nell'ombra pazienza quindi devo andare
con grande non è sbilanciato come faccio
a sapere che sei in vantaggio che hai
vinto tu sei così la tematica così larga
sono le palline ping e queste sono le
palline grandi io me la farei fallire
piccole perché sarà bisogno non è
pallina però sembrano non poco per
capire questo di quello lì iniziamo a
mettere la ciotola addio che tra i temi
e mettendo la peste il signore guerra
che non sai che così capiterà dopo
potrebbe capitarti qualcosa di più e
sono due
quindi vuol dire che posso mettere un
altro po dopo 9 10 della netta quanto
metterle da parte creato questa scatola
allora sono ben visibili
ok allora cosa scegliere invece
semitappa anche le orecchie per non aver
sentito un foro la la la
ma che ho fatto aspetta aspetta dovuto
vedere lo schermo
allora quale scegli grande o piccolo
secondo me free come mi è andata male
con farini è deciso che se con la è
meglio prendere grande perché almeno poi
sommerge tutte queste palline improperi
però se non è cosa non è colpa mia se
non è zuppa è pan bagnato e lo esigo
rogito è buono tra le 21 scelgo piccolo
per piccoli e grandi vedere come sto né
chi tra le arti e per gravi delitti
non lo facciamo cambio che ha seguito le
mie palline no viene visto quella balli
le brutte bestie sono i miei glitter che
sono i miei gradirà più belli sembrano
tipo delle parlano chiaro su ieri
sembrano delle pietre preziose perle
diamanti
si è appreso a foto ma allora pronti a
metterli c'era la colla dentro se li
riprende di qualità mettiamo il lettoni
bellissimi di iter che sembrano polvere
di stelle a scelta
mi è sembrato tempi dietro lire sono
proprio curioso di vedere come si
metterà con palline e kiefer giganti
bastava che sono stato più difficile
divertono troppo gradini si rompe tutto
chi sta secondo voi vi farà agazzi fare
bene i nostri live
certo forse una tematica viene dire che
alla fine del video come sempre dovete
votare se vinco io
oggi io sono team celeste dov'è finita
la mia bolletta eccola non si riescono
dirigere la vita depresso in base alla
bellezza azioni ai tre metri dello
studio ghiretti dimenticatevi di me ha
fatto dire accordo però per ora vero
com'è possibile perché ci affama credito
non avete anche la preside corn prendete
le ha detto ermete devi comodi anche se
non eravate como di tipo se stavate
correndo il video in piedi in equilibrio
per un piede molto comodo verso torno
questo è il penultimo turno frasi news
partiamo
però io devo scegliere gli ingredienti
ha lasciato di diventare allora questo
si che questa volta che canzone come
canzone del film della hbo numeri
coldebella quello milione praticato di
girare lo schermo è un piccolo devo
pensare bene pensa un certo tipo e già
scelto questo piccolo dei sicura se
fossero tuning animo si sono sicuro
perché altrimenti non avresti detto
molto bene e quindi esce alto di piccolo
[Risate]
quindi tu scegli ed era libero dopo
questa è la castello grave il rio sta in
questo caso non si è penalizzati nei
super piccolo né per grande per chiedere
aiuti il colorate grande è un posizione
giallo e invece piccolo e un piccolo
rosso rosa rosso si prova rosso lo avrà
in rosa che la volevo in realtà
maglietta che si imparano quelli de rosa
giallo giusto perché andiamo a mettere
in atto il colorante io devo mettere poi
in più perché ho preso quello grande
cosa fa tornare le palline rosa xvi rosa
io anch'io colorerà le palline rosa
giallo mostarda e bello che tu l'hai
sicuramente il sistema sembra tipo una
ricetta gli occhi alla zucca
no io chi alla rosa frenava mostarda che
può sicuramente tu invece sembra rito
all'araba è proprio lo slime di
halloween
fra poco arriverà uno slide di natale ma
se seguite da tanto tempo sapendo che è
vitale è fissato con isla e di natale
non so perché ma lui li ad ora così gli
slavi di natale è uno slide di natale
ancora una schifezza visto così vero sì
ho paura che vede il turismo come si era
un super fake
allora io non ho ben d'armi e vitale e
sceglie schermo già girato e abbiamo già
ordinate piccole l'ingrediente grande
fatto brutto tutto pratola fatto bene
scegli ritirato lo schema non le aveva
già girato non loro
questa è la decisione più importante di
tutte perché la decisione perché questo
è l'ultimo turno ovvero farei quello sul
turno penso che potrei migliorarlo il
tuo slime o potrai peggiorarlo ho paura
che non si tenesse un modo per
migliorarla questo è giusto
ovvero bruttissimo ha detto perché altre
sono queste palline che lo rovinano
parecchio brutto non mi è venuta l'idea
cuore invece di scegliere io mi schiero
i fogli l'efes crono calcio che i
bicchieri tu io mi rimetto la benda e
poi scelgono mischiando le carte in
tavola
che festa dai tagli celico fatto meglio
cento gesto piccolo regio in under aveva
omesso piccolo piccolo che volevo per
prendersi bello big maledetta ora visto
tutto laura invece vediamo
d'accordo soprattutto io volevo con la
bianca perché il bianco con il popolo
tante le palline stiamo molto bene
mentre preso il via la coltello che
colore è pronto a 0 l'importante che non
esce un verde ora farsele con marrone e
se sarà un colore bellissimo lerda
sappiamo già che quello di lavitola
sembrava slide stupendo vincerà
sicuramente kit perciò andiamo a mettere
la nostra colla tu sei super in
vantaggio sia la maggior parte delle
decorazioni perfette sia il colore bello
rosa sia la bolla bianca
vediamo che schifezza girate bene che
cosa brutta brutta brutta
ora vediamo come diventa il giallo
mischiato con il mio la marrone terrà
nel tuo che volevo dire vediamo che i
colori stasera se li lasci separati
questi colori esce più bello è possibile
perché però grigio o ti sto diventando
grigio veramente che la juve
terry 3 invece aspetta guarda non è di
barbato grigio è diventato è diventato
un giallo un po variato giallo brutto
sembrano polpette vabbè io proverò ad
attivarlo vediamo se queste polpette
ripassare magari non tutto bello questo
attivo caldera colore diventerà di un
giallo oro
guardate che map che altro sono stato io
bravissimo mischiare bene i colori a
scegliere attentamente sono giù sul
fondo
no come l'ho fatto sparire latina no non
si vede una coperta ho paura ho paura
che una volta attivato tutti quei
glitter così enormi cascheranno come al
solito attivarli così potete votare
[Musica]
ecco a voi lo slime troll stupendo
schiaccio la pallina escono tantissime
piccole bolle è stufo anche lui vivo
ballarini o ma penso che non ho mai
fatto uno slime del genere c'è quarto
produttore è stranissimo perché tutte
queste palline lo rendono molto diverso
da uno slam sempre presente uno squeeze
i ball
ricordate tutte le bolle che si formano
quando schiaccia la pallina
guardate wow
però devo dire che anche se è molto
brutto e molto anti stress perché
schiacciandolo il super antistress
[Musica]
guardate qua ma anche un bel po di suoni
ste cose mi ricorda minor a schiacciare
i brufoli ti guarda
e pure che l'istituto il posto di
brufoli non so perché ma si fa un po
schifo però è bellissimo da vedere o
create un nuovo tipo di sdraio lo slime
brufola guardate la chiesa
facciamo questo nuovo brufolo oddio le
mani tutte gialle l'est guardate un po
devo dire che è veramente rilassante
perché sempre veramente di schiacciare i
blues ricordate
vabbè fantastico ho creato il nuovo snai
brufa votate per noi drive gruppo di
vita spenta stupendo ecco il mio slime
oltre che piaciuto grandissimo ma perché
hai scelto la colla grande e usciva
anche bellissimo pfarrplatz ci sono
anche gli inter ci garantì 1 qui europei
è bella ma qui sembra zucchero filato
solo che è più bello allora se siamo
shocking super ricorra a posto dunque
siamo le bollicine beschi fa moltissimo
anche bello elastico e soprattutto del
mare stupendo va bene non si vedono
tanto le palline rosa perché rosa su
rosa meraviglioso e fantastico guardate
mercato ma secondo me il news live e
vispi times live brutto arriva in the
park
uno stand up all night live dallo slam
brufolo allora votate votate quale il
sondaggio se vinco io o se vincessi tale
e ora vi lasciamo 4 per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
vedete idee valide